[Music]
well there's been so much written about
the brothers the royal wrists and just
the extent to which they have fallen out
and I don't think anyone is going to
deny to you that there have clearly been
some quakes major problems in that
relationship last year wasn't a great
year for William and Harry but things
have got better and I know that William
and Harry are in touch there they are on
the phone they have been video calls
they forget their love of family
birthdays and of course I think with
Prince Charles not being well that that
really forced the brothers to sort of
pick up the phone to each other and get
back in touch the lot of reports of
Prince Harry feeling a bit homesick over
in LA and I think probably is the right
time really for round Fame to pick up
the phone to his brother and I'm told
that has happened
I think there is a sense of relief
probably on both sides that this tension
this high drama is now a thing of the
past the Sussex is er are free to get on
with their new lives
the Cambridge's can get back to their
old lives without all the upsetting the
drama that was clearly a big deal behind
the scenes I think Kate and William both
miss Perry and and Megan to a degree but
suddenly they miss Harry they they miss
having him around and they miss him
being a part of their lives
[Music]
how are you make an obviously needed
some time to settle into their new lives
and if it has been a busy time for Harry
and of course there have been first days
not least of Archie's you know now that
perhaps they've settled into their lives
in LA and this is the pattern to the
future I'm told that they feel a great
sense of freedom and they're really
enjoying their new lives and they're
enjoying being able to do things a bit
more on their terms that I would step my
family back from all I have ever known
to stick is to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
there was a lot of concern I could just
how involved Harry would be with his UK
charities when he left Britain but in
fact I'm told and that he's very much in
touch with most of the charities and
organisations every week phone calls
video conference calls he wants to hear
how these charities are doing he may be
thousands of miles away from us over in
LA but he's still touching base very
regularly he and Megan have hand-picked
the charities and organizations they
work with in person very carefully and
deliberately because their charities
that they care about the idea that they
would go over to America and just forget
about these charities and organizations
particularly in Harry's case that's the
big part of us like so long is
absolutely not the case
Harry keeps in touch with them very
regularly and possibly he's a little bit
homesick
I'm sure he's missing his friends and
his family at this time particularly and
he probably misses some of the people
that he works but don't forget he's he's
the patron of charities like well child
for many many years he's forged close
friendships there and Harry is a good
loyal friend so yes he's missing his
friends and yes he's picking up the
phones and back at home I think as soon
as it's safe to travel we'll see Megan
and Harry back in the UK I think we'll
see them in Africa I think this is a
couple who wanted to be a global couple
from the outset and I think as soon as
it's safe to do so traveling will be a
big part of their lives you know they
want to change the world they want to
get out there and I think we'll see them
traveling very extensively